former U.S president Donald Trump has
defended himself against a string of
criminal investigations in an address to
his supporters at his Mar-A-Lago
residence in Florida
he pleaded not guilty to 34 felony
counts in a Manhattan courtroom on
Tuesday the first sitting or former U.S
president to do so Gabriel Elizondo has
more from New York
there are images that will go down in
U.S history Donald Trump arriving at a
court in Manhattan
gone was a traditional Swagger that is
defined Trump's Persona today the former
president was uncharacteristically
somber as he became the first current or
former president to ever be charged with
the crime and this is what he's been
charged with the indictment being
unsealed before Trump in the courtroom
34 felony counts including falsifying
business records and other charges
stemming from a hundred and thirty
thousand dollar hush money payment to a
former adult film star
Donald Trump pleaded not guilty to all
the charges the case against Trump laid
out later by the Manhattan district
attorney Alvin Bragg
34 false statements
made to cover up other crimes
these are felony crimes in New York
state
no matter who you are
we cannot and will not normalize serious
criminal conducts however the indictment
did not impress Trump's legal team he's
he's frustrated he's upset but I'll tell
you what he's motivated and it's not
going to stop him and it's not going to
slow him down
earlier outside the courthouse the
anticipation had built to a fever pitch
as both supporters and detractors of the
former president gathered outside it's a
phony case everybody knows that
political persecution today is the
beginning of a long series of
finally after hours of waiting Trump's
motorcade arrived right past our camera
Donald Trump's motorcade arriving here
at the courthouse
he's in one of these vehicles
a historic moment it's a very scary time
it's a very fragile time for American
democracy and not only should Americans
be nervous but people around the world
should be as well this is just the start
of what likely will be a long legal
battle the next phase will be a trial
Trump's lawyers argue to the judge that
they don't want that trial to begin
until the middle of next year putting it
right smack in the middle of a
presidential campaign one in which it's
probable Trump himself would be a top
Contender for the Republican nomination
Trump left court without comment after
more than two hours inside later in the
evening when Trump returned to his
Mar-A-Lago estate in Florida he broke
his silence this fake case was brought
only to interfere with the upcoming 2024
election
and it should be dropped immediately
Trump showing his Defiance against a
judicial process that is very much in
motion Gabriel ozando Al Jazeera New
York
let's take a closer look at the case
against the former U.S president
statement from the District Attorney's
office said from August 2015 to December
2017 Trump orchestrated his catch and
kill scheme through a series of payments
that he then concealed through months of
false business entries in one instance
the D.A alleges thirty thousand dollars
was paid to a former Trump Tower Dorman
who claimed to have a story about a
child Trump had out of wedlock
in a second instance a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars was paid to a woman who
alleged she had a sexual relationship
with Trump
and in a third instance 12 days before
the presidential general election a
hundred and thirty thousand dollars was
wired to an attorney for an adult film
actress
Michelle Bernard's a lawyer political
analyst and the president of the Bernard
Center for Women politics and public
policy she says the district attorney
has a strong case against a former
president
it appears that his strategy is not a
new one it will be um to call the
investigation and the case fake uh just
like um we became accustomed to hearing
the former president use the terms fake
news uh I expect
um and strongly suspect that we will
continue to hear him say that this is a
a fake investigation it is a fake case I
believe that he will continue to say
that it is politically motivated
um and go back to to discuss a lot of
the things that we used to hear him say
um about many many things uh that were
happening here in the United States
including cases of quote-unquote
election fraud which we know never
happened what they presented us with
were just the bare bone facts there's
not a long Preamble there's not a long
statement of facts to go along with each
element of the offense that he has been
been charged with uh it feels like a
strong case if I if you asked me to rate
it one out of 10 with 10 being the
highest likelihood of him being found
guilty I would probably rate it at a
seven or an eight which is a high
probability it's not it's not a it's not
a sexy case
um it is a case of you know a falsifying
documents with the intent to commit
another crime what will be more
interesting is to see whether or not
this is a one and only case or if this
is the beginning of an avalanche of
cases that we are going to see coming
after the former president on the state
level and at the federal level